there were no survivors aboard an Air
Force Special Operations helicopter that
crashed last night
in Iraq we told you that first on
special report about that crash it is
the first deadly aviation accident for
US forces in Iraq or Syria since the
battle against Isis began in 2014
national security correspondent Jennifer
Griffin reports tonight from the
Pentagon about a tough week for US
military aviation and the military the
Air Force Pave Hawk helicopter crashed
while on a routine mission Ferenc
personnel between bases in western Iraq
all seven Americans on board were killed
initial reports say the special
operations helicopter hit a power line
near the city of alkine along the
iraq-syria border it comes one day after
a u.s. Navy f-18 Super Hornet crashed
off Key West flying on one engine as it
approached the runway at low altitude
one mile out the other engine failed the
jet rolled over as both aviators ejected
killing the pilot Lieutenant Commander
James Johnson and his weapons systems
officer lieutenant Caleb King who played
football at the Naval Academy and
graduated in 2012 the jet came from a
squadron that deployed last year aboard
USS George HW Bush carrying out
airstrikes against Isis the Pentagon
would not say whether the crash resulted
from years of combat and budget cuts
readiness is absolutely at the center of
what we're doing right now
I think pilots are going to be flying
more and training is going to pick up
today only half the Navy Super Hornet
fleet can fly president Trump spoke in
front of an f-18 at a Boeing hangar in
Missouri hours before the crash
the f-18 one of my favorite planes three
it's a work of art the 2018 defense
budget calls for forty six point four
billion dollars to rebuild US military
aviation eleven point seven billion
dollars to repair old jets thirty-two
point five billion to replace jets that
can't be repaired 2.2 billion to recruit
new pilots and mechanics Fox first
reported the Navy grounded its fleet of
training Jets after instructor pilots
complained of being poisoned in the
cockpit
a year later those oxygen problems have
now spread to the Air Force which
grounded its fleet of t6 trainers two
months ago the decision that the
secretary and I made to ground the fleet
we just had too many incidents that
caused our concern Fox News has
highlighted the shortage of parts that
forced Airmen to cannibalize planes and
search the desert boneyard for spare
parts a problem made worse by a shortage
of mechanics we have fallen behind in
supporting our men and women adequately
the bill that we're gonna vote on next
week for all its flaws begins to fix
those problems unless political
bargaining gets in the way of the
Pentagon getting the funds it says it
needs to fix these problems bread
Jennifer Griffin on top of the story
from the beginning at the Pentagon
Jennifer thank you